employees of Germany's Foreign
Intelligence Service have begun
familiarizing themselves with their new
surroundings agents will have two
computers at their disposal one for
internal use only with extra security
the first 170 staffers began moving in
on Monday with 4,000 more to follow in
the coming years the new BND
headquarters is now just a stone throw
away from German government buildings
meaning it's closer to political
decision-makers than ever before either
this direct and continuous interaction
will have many benefits this is the only
way for us to provide immediate answers
to questions that arise it will allow us
to serve the government and Parliament's
information needs more efficiently if
it's in devisor cadet via the German
government's biggest post-war
construction project was launched seven
years ago and has not been without
controversy blueprints that were
supposed to be top-secret went missing
and building costs far exceeded the 700
million euros originally budgeted
opposition lawmakers are skeptical all
in all this move will cost more than a
billion euros somewhere between 1.4 and
1.7 million and I don't think it's going
to result in the BND providing any
better service for the people of Germany
for bethod but the BND is full of praise
for its transparent new headquarters in
the heart of Berlin it even has a
visitor center complete with an
exhibition on spying